put up the tweet that just caught my eye
and i'm like you know what i gotta get
my friend here
on the show to account daniel jeremiah
we're about two to three years away from
personnel departments not caring about
40 times
the game gps data is going to replace it
and these are the words that really cut
deep who cares what he ran in the 40 i
know exactly how fast he ran in game
conditions and i have five years of data
for context and i know he's not saying
that himself
he's putting those are the words that
actual executives are saying and i'm
like
what are we doing is he trying to daniel
jeremiah are you trying to end fight
club is that what you're trying to do
are you trying to end it look what are
you doing what's going on this this
has been perceived by some as a
retaliation
um for what the slander that you gave
fred the sled at the combine
and i tried to introduce yes when you
tried to name the sled that was used out
there as fred the sled i thought it was
awful and
belichick himself loved it um
and the rest of your scouting and
coaching and evaluation community loved
it and i
i accepted it i came around and fred the
sled but um
this one this one cuts deep daniel cup's
very deep well
there's a lot of layers here i will i
will say this there's a lot of irony as
you can tell i'm in the car right now
yes i uh i spent the day i spent the day
in uh the morning in orange county where
a bunch of these guys are working out
yes and kind of put a bunch of these
players through like a mock pro day so
they can get
ready because there's no combine just
going to give them a dry run
so these kids can go out and really
perform and do their best at their pro
day
right so i did find it interesting that
i was out this morning timing
40s uh before coming on to join you rich
and i gotta say
it's the first time since 2012 where i
was really at 40
at uh pro day setting where my you know
you're kind of running it and your
numbers matter and i i feel
i felt kind of like a house cat today
like i was back out in the wild and it
was just
just so uh is
the irony even heightened by the fact
that you used gps to get to the site to
time your 40s
daniel if i could have just driven my
car
next to them while they ran i would have
done it
they wouldn't allow that on the field up
there see but this is my point daniels
there's always gonna be like sure
you know uh the sec is gonna have chips
in the shoulder pads of these
but there's always going to be d3 small
school people that you're going to need
to
get out the old timer and figure this
thing out the 40-yard dash will always
be necessary
always it's all it's always going to
exist
i am with you on that it's always going
to exist and there will be times where
it's help where it helps
i would say that its significance in the
process
is has already been diminished to a
degree and is going to continue down
that way i still think we do it
you still do it at the you know at the
combine and we still
we we've been doing the gps numbers at
the combine for a while now
too so we have both sets of information
there
um but when i've talked to to gm's and
guys around the league that that is
entered into the lexicon over the last
two years
in a big way and it's this guy was in
the 94th percentile or this guy's
fastest time was in the you know the
80th percentile for his position
these these gps numbers are coming more
and more and more
into kind of the common conversations
that you have on these players
yeah i know but uh i just we you know uh
it is
it is obviously something but to me
look man i i i know that you know you'd
rather use the gps
uh in somebody's shoulder pad to see how
fast someone ran against auburn
or against the ohio state rather than
having charlie casually close one eye
and try and figure out whether his
is actually moving accurately i i
totally get that
but you you're you are telling me that
there will always still be a 40-yard
dash of the combine right the scouts
aren't going to just
toss it right yeah i mean i we're i
think we will still have it
and i still think you'll use the you
know you'll have the 40 time but i think
the gps number will will continue to
carry some significance
and it's going to get more significant
as we go forward i mean i can envision a
day
where you're running you know the
distance of 40 yards
and then we have a gps number there and
we have a speed limit and we could have
a police officer there right at the
finish line to see if whether or not you
get a ticket or not
don't laugh at that i mean it's funny
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show all right let's talk uh let's talk
a little bit here
uh before we get to this year's draft
class i think it was at the draft in
dallas
where i was first hearing some rumors
about keep an eye out for seattle
drafting a quarterback
i think that's how far back it was the
first time i heard like wait a minute
something's not right with seattle and
russell wilson something's going on
what is going on there daniel what what
why is there constant smoke
coming out of that building in regards
to this coach quarterback relationship
that still
exists to this day what's going on yeah
it's a great question and and good
recall by you i mean i don't say who all
was in the vehicle but i remember
you know us being in the vehicle on the
way to the draft and we were having
these conversations like is this really
possible like it was legitimate
legitimate information so it's been
going on for a little bit
of time here i thought the telling thing
in that article
was the mention of the two quarterbacks
right he's kind of caught in between
the legacy of brady with the
championships or breeze
with the numbers and he hasn't been able
to really get to either one of those
sides he's been kind of right in the
middle and that's the formula that
pete's
that pete's use so it's a belief it's
peace belief in the philosophy
and russell's belief in himself and
eventually that's going to come a time
where that's just not going to work
anymore because it's a different it's a
different goal in mind
uh for both of them so i i the problem
is here's the thing you say well they're
not
you know see the ceos are not happy with
him saying this stuff publicly
russell's not happy that's why he's
obviously saying these things publicly
but how the heck do you get fair value
in a trade for somebody like russell
wilson i just don't know how you do that
because
everybody loves to make the hypothetical
trades but they always forget to tell
you who's going to be playing
quarterback for the seattle
exactly well that's why i said you know
the two words are geno smith you know
and
and so um that said though
there are two teams on the east coast
that do have sort of the if this is true
or not what he's looking for
an upgrade into a glitzier lifestyle uh
for he and his
his wife and his family um there are two
teams in the other conference on the
east coast that can flip a quarterback
that's young and under contract uh back
to seattle if if they want it
the jets in darnold and tua and miami do
you think miami and the jets
uh make a move like this whether it's
for wilson or
watson over the next six weeks before
you and i
sit uh assuming uh socially distant in
cleveland ohio for the draft
daniel um you know it's interesting when
you look at those two quarterbacks and
those two teams i would say
miami could would make sense with both
right obviously
everybody's going to make sense for
deshawn watson at his age and his skill
set
um but i would say with their team kind
of ready to win
more so right now i would think russell
wilson would make some sense there
um the jets to me would be more of a
watson or the draft
would make more sense i don't think
russell's as great a fit there it's just
going to be you you watch team every
week rich i mean
they've they've got some foundational
pieces but you know they've got a lot of
picks this year next year and that's
going to kind of be key for them
to be a really good team but i don't
think that i don't think they're ready
right now for russell wilson
yeah i guess but you you can covet what
you see you know and obviously if
anybody knows what
what russell wilson can do to a defense
it's somebody
you know who has been trying to
coordinate against him
um you know and the jets new head coach
there
so what do you think the jets uh
game plan is right now march first here
we go
second overall who wants who and what do
they do
over the next six weeks best guess right
now dj
well i think i think they they for sure
check their voicemail every day to see
if
necessarily is called back uh i'm sure
that that's where the day starts
uh and then and then once you get
through that part of your day
um you're trying to get to what i
believe will probably about a month from
now probably the first of april
by that time you'll have a comfort level
with these draft
kids you'll know not only have you seen
their pro days see them throw live
you'll have a chance to have had
multiple interviews with them you know
over
zoom to get your coaches comfortable
with them your coaches by now should
have
a feel for for sam the new coaches
should know exactly
how they feel about him and how he fits
and not only how he fits in you know
physically but also
financially into what they want to do so
to me i think you've got to get to
the point where you can say whoever your
quarterback is in this draft whether
it's wilson's
fields lance whoever that that they've
passed your physical
um and that you've seen them live and
they've checked the boxes in terms of
the interviews and all that stuff then
you decide comparing them versus sam so
to me again every day i'd be checking in
on uh
on sean watson to see if there's any any
chance you get something going there
but outside of that i think what this
has gonna have to play out till we get
to
april all right let's check on your
latest mock draft 2.0 no shock here
trevor lawrence and then you do have
the jets selecting zach wilson so that's
who they would if they decide to stay
put
and then decide that donald will be
playing elsewhere that's what they would
do
that's that's who they would choose
would be the byu quarterback that's just
my
you know my mock draft version here
right a couple more to go but as i
as i kind of look at it i think that's
the one that makes the most sense for
them
um so that's where i have them going and
then
and then it becomes interesting i mean
the fascinating thing rich is going to
be what happens then with sam
so if you take if you take wilson or
fields whoever you take there
or lance right um everybody's kind of
looked at it and said
okay do you get a second round pick for
sam is it a second round pick this
year's second round pick next year could
you maybe even
squeeze a late one out of one of these
teams and i'm sitting here going man
what if
if i'm situated where the jets are i'm
trying to get a pick
swap you know they pick 34 at the top of
the second round
um i i would be trying like crazy to see
if i could find one of those teams
that's picking
you look at where carolina is um you
look at where
a team where's washington picking i
think they're what uh
they're a little bit further back um but
you've got
denver denver and carolina i believe
what eight nine in that range
right i'd be trying like heck to see if
i could get let's
let you get sam darnold and pick 34 we
get pick eight or nine and the jets end
up with two picks in the top ten
huh because the jets can just start i
guess
stockpiling that stuff i i um i'm trying
to to me you take the court you take the
quarterback at two right right
then you're depending on what happens in
free agency um
you could take you could take a really
good offensive lineman there eight or
nine to plug in with a really good
addition and free agency with mckay
beckton and a top 10
offensive lineman now you've got a
really good offensive line to work with
here
and you'd still have pick 23
which you could pick or you could trade
back you've got a lot of options with
what you could do there
i'm just saying there there's a way with
sam if they did decide to move sam i
think you could come up with a formula
where you could end up with a couple top
ten picks few minutes left here with
daniel jeremiah my colleague
uh at the nfl network we should be at
the combine right now where we are uh
i'm you know you and i have been told
we're get ready to go to the draft in
person in cleveland which we're very
excited about
uh right here on the rich eisen show um
so
justin fields to atlanta uh trey lance
to carolina i saw
mac jones to new orleans what is going
on
you're all i'm also hearing a lot about
mac jones maybe top ten
carolina what's going on with this
alabama quarterback
what do what are you what are you
thinking about this and that that mix
right there to the saints
you like that one huh yeah i like to fit
with the saints and they've got to see
what's going to happen with jamis and
what they want to do with that position
but
i think he really fits because the the
skill set he has his strengths are his
uh you know ability to see the field his
ability to throw accurately he's not
somebody that's got
a huge arm he's not a great athlete uh
but we've seen drew towards the latter
portion of his career you know once he's
lost a little bit
uh see this offense still click at a
pretty good pace when you've got
somebody that's a good decision maker
that's accurate
um like like jones is but to me the
interesting thing with mac is
this top like top ten man i just there
was no no point when i watched him
i thought that was a top 10 pick just
because he does not have that
that type of juice you know when you
talk about arm strength
or you think about his ability to create
and make plays and he's a very tough kid
to evaluate because
you can sit back in a rocking chair
behind that offensive line
and you've got a lot of good options out
there in the field so he's
he's difficult to evaluate i would say
you're seeing him really kind of rise up
through this portion because he's an
incredible kid and the more people
around him and the more you hear about
his intelligence and work ethic i think
people are really really buying on that
so uh let's try and put some pieces
together here um
from college to the pros um are you of
the belief that despite the uh
instagram video of him pushing to sled
around that breeze is is going to retire
does the evaluation community think that
that is going to
in fact happen yeah you know that's
where my
my son works out in the summer there
with todd dirk in there in san diego
i've seen drew doing that
sled drill a bunch over the last couple
years but uh i i
i still think he stays retired uh i
think he's never gonna stop being a
competitive person who's gonna work out
and stay in great shape i thought maybe
that got blown up a little bit
okay all right uh and we're you know
alex smith
rumored to be uh released by the
washington football team
a lot of people connecting dots to his
college coach urban meyer and he'd be
the perfect guy to
teach trevor lawrence how to be a
professional but
maybe he's thinking you know i didn't
come back from lunch leg surgery to be
mr chips here
uh i want my opportunity where do you
think he might make sense for a team
that
that could potentially go to the
playoffs with alex smith as washington
was doing because of his play last year
yeah i mean the two the
the two that make the most sense to me
um to me first and foremost would be
jacksonville
and you know i he did such a great job
with mahomes he's probably maybe he's
being punished for that
but uh man that's that would be my
target if i was jacksonville to try and
bring him in and then i would just add
we'll see keep an eye on new england
what goes on
up there because we know bill's formula
right but he wants to
not turn the ball over make good
decisions and win with defense and
special teams and alex smith can do that
i love that food for thought um
and what'd you before i let you go news
of the day what do you think of j.j
watts signing
in arizona dj yeah that i just i mean i
i found that out while i was out there
on the on the field today i was shocked
i didn't i did not see that one coming
it didn't seem like a
a real natural fit but um you get a
chance to if they can stay healthy up
there up front
um and reunite with hopkins i guess all
they need is watson they can just get
the whole gang back
no i think they got murray but why don't
you think it would be a fit you'd think
you know cause can jj he can play
interior right i mean if oh
jj whatever he can fit as a as a player
i just thought he was going to try and
cherry-pick a team that he thought could
get him to the
winner's circle you know you don't think
arizona circle
i i like i like arizona but i would have
thought to me i looked at a team like
buffalo
and as far as they went last year and
the pieces that they had in place
right um and i i know you can talk about
the the
murray miracle that they they beat them
but to me i thought buffalo was closer
to the finish line and
i thought jj was going to go some place
would be maybe be that last piece
right um i think arizona can be a
playoff team but i don't think that they
were one piece away from a championship
dj appreciate the time again no more
even if you think it don't don't tweet
about that uh about the 40-yard dash
because if you they come for the 40
what's next football on a stick we can't
have it
you know what i mean like let's just
keep let's just keep old school old
school
let's keep it let's keep it healthy
let's keep it young and fresh best we
can
yeah you know mike yep let's let's do
that matt called why we were talking by
the way so i gotta call him did he
really
yeah he did i wish i could have
three-way i went three-way demand there
can you imagine how pissed you've been
if i would
if i would have said hey mike you're on
the air by the way we're showing a
photograph of
me with football and stick with him
right there and once again
he's not td he wasn't into football in
his deck he wasn't into it as much as i
clearly was but that picture say a
thousand words right there
all right dj thanks for the call you
take care see you
tell mike i said hi there's uh there's
daniel jeremiah hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here